hello all right long time no see yeah
you uh you doing okay how's the family
uh pretty good I left them back in b1 oh
they're safe back there we cleared that
out yeah yeah we freshly moved in we
knew it was safe
yeah totally safe great real estate in
there you know what I miss I miss
long-range flashlights I don't got me in
more trouble than it was worth no in
this one you know I miss long-range
flash right dedicated all my brainpower
to hearing clickers so you guys mark are
you trying to listen hey everybody come
here and get some of this I'm busy
hacking come here I'm awesome of this
mom and Haken all right don't move
hacker I got mad packs nice Oh mom
what'd you do to no move mother nothing
happened Marathon Man I mean sprint man
thanks man all right that gets rid of
this ammo pack so now I know I did get
him okay we have to talk this entire
area in that voice I remembered I've got
a dentist appointment I need to go over
this Gessle all right get a circle
you're leaving us on the dope and dry
I'll gladly change what order we go into
the circles every time that really makes
it easy to remember yeah had their
flashlight on like an [ __ ] just gotta
go back over here I flash might once
last round eye on him for like half a
second before I realized they think bad
was happening
you just you get a certain number of
hours in you just start to get really no
no no good sorry that bit was over sorry
I didn't mean it for step back it's over
I didn't even get my my two cents in
Marco you might want to not do that why
just a just a piece of advice don't just
getting them dancing right come on guys
yeah I know what you talk about I've
always known what you're talking about
I'm terrified to turn on my flashlight
ever again they're far away it's fine
considering what happened last time
I don't think it was my flashlight then
that did it now it's definitely
definitely I'm gonna exonerate myself
from what happened and uh exoneration
overruled
dammit I know that was an option I got
them yeah you'd never take advantage of
here I didn't know was a thing I hereby
exonerate myself of everything no look
exoneration overruled God me so many
[ __ ] items already that's fine this
is not a bad sign at all yeah yeah yeah
it's how this game always is it wants
you to have it wants you to have the
loot well then here's another to use too
little refill there so there's all the
tool refills we need yeah here's another
to use some ammo and there's a for use
over here right format for use oh my
goodness I've got 10 use 10 refills of
tool up here we should carry these bad
boys back towards the other end of this
now it's actually like this next area I
think is the place with the choke point
so this is great actually yeah this is a
good placement I ideal calm down
residual bit that was like our sports
[ __ ] and snaggle-toothed had a baby /
late
thanks I don't feel bad having mine on
if Marzulli [ __ ] flashlight right
our strategy has a run to the room and
blind them with the Sun look my brain
works at such a high clock speed I just
memorize it from a single flash that the
clickers it's just like okay there's one
on the left as well
yeah there's two farther beyond one but
there might be far enough away if you
they're not glowing the ones going oh
there's three there's three there's two
right next to each other over on that
wall I can get this one corn popcorn
juice no okay so there's two mother yeah
yeah Kenneth you need to see you need
some light right that was necessary just
Russia
I'm sorry swung and you better go oh
Jesus do well dude countdowns are so oh
boy Wow wait there I thought they were
triggering it it's fairly fine well
we're totally fine right now
everything's fine don't worry about it
oh [ __ ] we used to do that word [ __ ] the
head wait we haven't been doing that for
literally an hour 30 minutes of playing
this game I even I know we don't do that
anymore
hey we have totally a bed in the rules
that we had established last time but
I'm gonna go back to those and presume
everyone around me will go back to the
rules that we have going here we're fine
we're really smart boys now we don't
need rules yeah we know what the deal is
get in or get out mark turn off your
[ __ ] with halogens in it yeah I do
actually
mark to 702 long range tool refill over
here is this the only guy down here can
I smack them dudes Mac there you go
there's another one that's not away I
say there's pears Todd's makam mark you
know what I miss what's up it's the
searing light of a thousand suns
looting everything in creation formal I
can't see anything
perfume art you see that one way anyone
up by mark check it I can turn off my
flashlight if you need to see it was
there last night
yeah did someone say light you guys are
good owner good good so did someone say
never want to see again that someone say
damaged retinas I'm kind of sad that
there's no more long-range flashlights
around yeah I am jealous just the one
just the one I think on this level
just the one just a one flashlight
actually another tool refilled to use
there are so many a munitions man I know
about you guys that I'm down to start a
scan sequence like I feeling wild right
now oh [ __ ] party boy slides on boys be
ready what are you gonna melt a hole in
the door so we ready ready as I am I'm
very ready all the time I don't trust
how nice this has been going now just
fit we're just so good after beating b2
that it's just a lot easier yeah yeah I
ignore the music it's fine I don't hear
music oh good that's great are you okay
I hear something on the other side of
the door
you smell burnt toast hmm how can you
see not anymore
sorry I got my teeth whitened recently
[Laughter]
great it's spooky fun's over
wait that was fun yeah that was the best
part compared to what's next do not
enjoy that if you didn't enjoy that this
is not gonna go well dude those no I
enjoy pain and misery oh okay you're
gonna love what's great yeah you're
gonna love this I think he's gonna love
it all right so what are we setting up
for should I do the thing what are we
what we're doing I mean you may want to
set up all we have are something so I
just wanna start blasting we just gotta
go we got do the circle and then I said
we just gotta run back to the joke so we
can do it now and just run over and set
up quick right I think so yes the thing
yeah who's dedicated runner monkey very
good fighting in this game anyway okay
I'm glad Interlake explained just okay
I'm running in front there we go he is
it front what to fall back you were
looking into the thud the light he was
shining ahead of you like now he was
light in here now it's much better all
right mark you're gonna have to call
where the choke is remember I think yeah
this is this door here I think if we
plan on the other side of this door just
like all in a row like all of our
sentries right up on this ass of this
just plop them up at that door we stand
behind it and we shoot like hell so I
don't have to do the code yet right I
can just wait a minute and then run back
once it's yep done er more gunnery yep
get him boys let's try not to shoot
don't strike back and forth too much
you're crouched if you're in the front
because there's we're not all in the
same line of fire here
okay so far so toasty uh-huh good gonna
strengthen the heparin um dude oh here
we go my big boy not for long all right
on Big Boy okay do you want me to wait
mark to give us time I don't know
see the thing is I really don't know if
they keep going like it's an alarm
all right well there's only 30 seconds
I'm just gonna go ahead and do it I
think all right yeah go for I'm gonna
seems like it's stopped
Joe get your turrets picked up and get
them refilled I'm gonna use the main
goal you didn't grab their code what's
the code evil yeah I'm full up on tons
of okay whoa Oh more more one more
actually we're okay we're okay okay so
we got a minute 22 Lieut okay yes get
tool refills there should be a few in
that does anybody need ammo I stupidly
didn't switch between my primary and
secondary okay none of us did so well
yeah it's okay I I'm rockin med packs
I have refills so I can I'm gonna get
mine going here there's one here yeah
there's two right here I'm gonna place
my turret a little more forward just so
they're not all hitting the same dude
and ways I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
this ammo pack and just top some of us
up so I saw Marnie yeah I'm okay I'll
switch to my secondary oh ho that is a
dangerous sound it's a hell of a sound
right here we go boys I'm gonna be up
here use your secondaries a little bit
that way ammo packs are there's
chocolate [ __ ] I'm using shot a shot
that's why I'm not gonna I'm up closer
oh I agree
okay yes I feel very nervous next to
these orange light you're so fine I feel
very nervous did they go for us yep
pretty low low all right i'ma head back
cool dude a man
you got it it is gang a reactor gang
coming in spicy gang squad gang squad it
is funny they always surge right when
the person leaves is like oh wait out
yeah we're all dead Bob hi that's what
happened last time I played this one
doing the coats and he would be fine and
he'd be like all right I'm gonna do the
code and then we would be like okay
looking pretty good oh oh my god they
all just do the same thing again loot
and shoot yeah looting shooting this
this one on the wall is mine is that a
bad you got hit by everyone's shock
because I said I went ahead cuz I was
like okay looks clear and there was one
dude and he must have like stuck his
like the hair on the top of his head
above the rim they all turned orange and
nails you felt like it yeah felt like it
yeah crouched Jones was here in the
front reloading oh is that a big boy
yeah somewhere back there
that got closed water big guy you done
all right I'm not going out there
I'm not doing it I think it's safe with
ammo so I'm picking up my sentry so you
can go okay mine looks like it's out of
and one more down there
oh god please not me turret code is poke
oh okay I'm out of I'm anomalous hope I
didn't I don't have any century ammo
left yeah you and Bob oh I've got one
brief fill here son oh Jesus oh no Bob
did it no go I didn't I didn't ah [ __ ]
I thought we were still the first phase
I didn't go oh I'm an idiot all right
it's my own fault
round two baby around three round three
again young baby Shawn please stop
moving
I'm gonna go farther he did yeah kind of
all right I'm gonna make sure I do the
code this time at least it didn't reset
to the very beginning that would that
would be yeah now we know what happens
when you don't do what you're supposed
to do yeah so that's cool right
reloading um all right incoming whoa
whoa what the hell yeah that's crossfire
just aim at their heads and shoot them
simple big boy
oh these centuries are out of ammo
aren't they all right shoot good guys I
believe in you
I gotta go yeah we're fine I'm nailing
heads oh he's dead all right
Oh second big guy
nice okay choo-choo-choo-choo I got the
code don't worry looking up my century
don't worry don't really find nothing to
be worried about it spoke there we go
but totally fine totally fine I have one
more tool tool refill yeah I'm at zero
there's still another enemy Oh big guy
yeah mark is at zero in Sean's of zero
I am also at zero I guess yeah she's in
front of yourself then we need to we
push deeper and get some more of those
tool raposa yeah we'll probably have to
fall back to the next zone
guys you might want to hurry up step on
the gas anymore tool yeah we gotta fall
back we gotta go farther to the next
zone I didn't know my sentry told the
other ones we ran out there I feel like
that was helpful to have it at the end
so I dropped it in oh well just pat
yourself on the back why don't you
alright I will no longer share
strategies from you yeah I've no I have
no century on this one that's okay we
don't need it it's for chumps if I do
where we putting them we can basically
hold this bridge they'll come across so
with this we'll have a longer longer
line of sight
if you want I'll be low ground oh my god
they're storming the beach reloading
okay this is pretty good it's not so bad
this is fine some nice long sightlines
going on in here yeah oh they're getting
further
I'm just waiting reloading waiting for
him okay they got close oh oh oh
these headshots are so satisfying uh-huh
debit there's one back left shooter as
to one of those was not dead on the
ground there Oh mark I'm in trouble
yep okay getting [ __ ] me when you fail
it you have to do the same wave again
yeah cat damnit
it's all good tell me apparently I don't
know what I I was the I was obsessed
with that the first time we ran this and
now I'm not even thinking about the code
thing too busy killing bro kinda yeah
this bridge is pretty good yeah who
needs I describe the tool refill my
mighty my who needs sentries was like a
rhetorical who needs me I said who needs
them
and now you got him I don't want I did I
didn't get any hahahaha the one who
wanted it didn't get it Wade
oh you know this friendly fire in this
game right Blake right it's not Wade
sounds in bed huh got me hey I like
these Peppard shuts huh why are they
going down are they going down I think
cuz you guys are on the right they're
following that way oh they're just
trying to be silly I see I see I see
it's okay
oh you're still here what the [ __ ]
reloading all right time to go for code
going running not forgetting this time
it's rush totally fine don't worry guys
this happen ironic to go an ironic name
in a while code oh you're not like
you're not lucky you're not dead
Oh Allie then we're just doing it the
hard way that's what's up extra balance
is well we this levels not hard enough
god you [ __ ] long range piece of [ __ ]
alright we are on our last legs good
thing it's round sev I'm here what are
you doing oh you a are you giving me
some I don't deserve that at all it's
okay man it's okay hey it's our last
round yeah that's right that's right you
guys just want to stay standing that
doorway not come in I'd be ideal yeah
had to say it
reloading excuse me mister friend
I'm going back nice you can do it
friends we got it don't worry Ohama
good yeah boy knows how to spell
four-letter words
oh god where'd you come from
oh really oh you y'all where are you
God's for you everything every wine this
one guy with the the agility of a God I
am at 20% health do we have any health
packs left yeah I've got one Bria I got
the ammos one one handle so mark oh no I
just did sorry sorry looks like are we
defending the same place this is the
same every time
I think this is probably the best place
we can go and then yeah pretty much
there's are apparently two more tool
refills somewhere it's neat
good yeah ones in zone 65 and one is in
this room right here
which is on one with 65 one okay okay
well here we go who should I get the
ammo to for the centuries it's just hold
on for a second more pressing matters
wait
[Applause]
reloading
wolf
[Music]
they pushed up a lot that time nope big
boys coming in oh my god die you become
if I bet what's a [ __ ] thing die what
does the RNA pop to pop I think rain
rebate boy for some reason like rains
dudes less damaged from like SMDs or
something I don't know why I got so many
right interesting I'm going have fun
dude we got Wow I got tongued my dudes I
got wait wait ah so close to the end
yeah oh 14% hell 22% hell are you doing
show you get over there I'm great I
can't I can't see you from the top yeah
alright Bob down to you up to you you
got it you got this baby
there's one or two big guys on the
bridge and luckily we're right there
their tongues are long bombs long body
big
oh I just got just got whooped on from
the side that's what you want would you
[ __ ] die there we go you got it Bob
we believe in you door if you get this
there's only two more rounds hey big guy
how you doing I'm here I'm nice he's the
man Bob we've got 20 seconds guys we're
so fine you don't have to see it
everyone just needs to hey I'm across
the bridge going well the other two were
opposed uh I know you were working hard
there too were just up literally you
start moaning yeah we got it we got it
we got it got it
aim true boys all right you get the last
of it Bob you MVP you yeah that I do dot
I'm holding up the team here holding up
holding back same difference right
at this rate does it really matter die
you long-legged long-legged big ass huge
lips buxom Beauty oh damn she sick
though yes is and he is and they are I'm
gonna go now so to try and get back as
quickly as possible so I can help I'm
down from behind Bob so your plan you
all down yep yeah Oh Oh sick bright side
we're basically done yeah this would
this is last room fake you did it Bob
just kite them forever uh nice perfect
I'm gonna survive two minutes you got it
I hear very distant shots yeah yeah
everything's fine
everything's so fine right now it's
everything so fine and good right now
yeah kiting them way that it's happening
okay good something that went really
well
it went really well no Jesus pretty
close all things considered there yeah
what things considered some of the
things that went wrong early on we blew
our load for their centuries I think way
too early we should have saved some of
those for later rounds yes that was the
problem
alright well I'm done offering helpful
suggestions
next I did no one notice or is everyone
just being really nice other than mark
okay I'll take it I'll take it okay to
explain what happened
I [ __ ] up two separate rounds that we
had to redo during that run so we
literally were past done we did nine
rounds I don't remember them I didn't
wait a minute redo it though did we yes
he just said at the bottom
wave three initiating even though we had
just killed wave three it was entirely
my fault that that went so far so wrong
at the end
I'm gonna go pistol just because I want
to if we're picking our shots if we go
to that
but like I think we've got this no
clickers can these rooms have stuff in
them yeah we had to clear a few rooms on
the way in before I don't hear anything
here I hear something I think we're good
no no no wait no no there's a thingy
that's clicker over here that's two of
them should keep my flashlight on yeah
of course you've been playing for five
hours now man come on it's true I should
know better by now
oh there you were oh I didn't even see
it Bob you was going you were going for
that one weren't you I was I was
sneaking right up to him all right right
right
sneaking sneak what is that word sneak
another tool for use tool I hear another
click look II suppose I must be in the
next room
no no it's above me I scared it more
more MORE
oh my god it's gonna get hit god I just
killed God [ __ ] don't make fun of me
that's kind of how you sound to me most
times O'Toole mortals yes oh medkit yeah
rub it all on you
I thought I had a good flashlight and
then I stood next to my feelings of
inadequacy who seemed to follow me
everywhere I go there's nothing writer
than the Sun don't shine that thing like
like that don't do it come on up what
what's up nothing here I'm gonna worried
over nothing
I bet if I pulled my gun out and I start
shooting not a thing would happen I bet
I feel you know what am i right about
yeah I bet Oh bang see nothing oh [ __ ]
nothing nothing Aven fine I don't think
we have a limited ammo on this nothing
no yet for piddly bullets big boy
flashlight I cuz I know where there's oh
is it always in the same place I think
so it's been there like the last three
times we tried this ooh right there hey
guys underneath is it one there's two at
least okay here a second one but I don't
see a second one what's going on guys
see something you love to see it you
love all right oh it's gonna say hurry
up there's two more
Oh fun fun stuff the more you need how
you need light you need help you need
okay I'm up let's do this all right I'm
just gonna sprint at him oh damn it I
got when I get victimized by your guys's
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right de mine
trusted with this or someone that's
taking this w god I'm ready we'll just
yell at you if you get it wrong this
time
yeah Bob it's gonna be real annoying
with the colors yes destroy me daddy
it's just fake Oh France oh that's what
I'm gonna do that'll work flashing man
follow anybody but my own destiny
follow me not even going to the forward
show pointer we're just gonna hang on
that bridge I mean I think the bridge is
great this sight line like I think the
bridge is better we'll just have to make
sure we right up and grab this stuff
from the front I think the bridge is
good the bridge
great oh this pistol is the good stuff
I'm sneaking up don't shoot me i you
think my aim is so bad
yes hey boys come on down I dare you I
dare you to get closer to me all right
I'm going
don't die nerds the century ammo doing I
didn't even use mine on that I didn't
even use mine on that I didn't even use
I I use mine on that we have lockers up
here we didn't grab [ __ ] yes this one
away up here okay wait were you asleep
at the wheel again I think the pistol is
the way to live right now the pistol
more I'll pop it some domes yeah it's
pretty good there is nothing that can
stop us from succeeding this round
except for me I'm gonna be up close with
a shoddy yo you're gonna do it to them
okay give me ranged [ __ ] yeah yeah oh
hey they're not mine didn't me much yeah
you're learning straight down the barrel
they're just coming at me which is cool
if I have my flashlight off they won't
even know I mean I'm not I'm not lying
they're they're kind of ignoring me
there yes they're thirsty for me tell
you man the americorps just like extra
centuries on the side just shotgun to
the [ __ ] out of them reloaded I'm going
for the thing you got a none c8 harder
under smash how is he not getting this
guys I don't know he's a bit of a
dum-dum oh there we go
Volkswagen got it dude this is great
this is great you guys this [ __ ] mom
down yeah cuz if you hit him first I
think they just don't even care I got a
feeling that century's gonna peep over
it man
the right one is fine his fine it's fine
it's fine it's party's mark Wow all
right you you good you good you good
yeah you guys you guys you're you can
just a couple in this escape of an
existence oh wow they're good ballers
you good yeah yeah you guys smoke bro
you guys got vape you guys babe no one's
coming for me oh no a doorman got babe
Bob my turn is insane what's happening
right at me
holy [ __ ] that's not good it's okay I
can handle it I'm a big boy all right
okay I'm running I'm running now make
sure you guys make sure those big boys
tell me tell me the train okay as soon
as it comes up make sure you tell me
okay
all right whoa no hey my homework I know
nope nope oh God
sauce fast fast die Jesus Christ come on
dive down what
I just got quadruple licked well are you
gonna shoot him tree have a shotgun yes
- John wait what are you doing getting
hit what no that's more that's more ants
finds a couple oh sorry it's it's for
help I'm down
oh no oh there's a big boy there's a
large fellow here no you're seeing
things yeah what are you talking about
okay get your head out of your ears
okay I'm gonna switch out for pistol
duty my shotguns like it's not yeah are
you gonna take your spot on the stairs
yeah go for it yeah is it cool to post
up on this bridge up here oh yeah that's
fine I was standing right here and just
waiting to receive them with my shotgun
I wasn't even
I wasn't even pistol sniping so but that
should be fine
the high ground is good you could also
stand on top of the box next to wade
you just have to dodge the right this is
good too like that fell back there yeah
as they're coming it's a great time to
like talk about strategy to the real
estate value in this place pretty good
I'm coming for you Bob
they really know that I'm here I'm not a
sneaky-ass mark I guess yeah they know
I'm here now as well maybe cuz I'm up on
the bridge I'm too far for them to think
about getting you're not you're not
faking aggro yeah maybe all right I'm
going right now I'm going right now left
side is not covered wowser guard in case
I forget how to spell I need that I need
extra tries oh there is a lot of them
here I heard a scream like there's
is coming oh I have 2% health why
because I got hit a lot why dude don't
don't do that I'm gonna lay my century
in this room now all right Shawn I got
regular mo for you yeah who needs
regular mo I've got a for you sir on me
too these regular ammo everybody we're
all pretty topped own oh yeah Shawn
needs it nerd what's happening boy amp
yeah you want to go back to your spot on
the side and I'll play the bridge or
yeah I'll do that yeah I'll be a bridge
baby yeah the other bridge baby I'll go
to my hole again I like this hole
what's it go good hole out oh yeah when
they know you're there you're there they
are they really know oh wait you can go
up for help buddy so one bad glad to
reload Jesus there were like six of them
on yeah he's got one that's what took me
down before was just one of them
remember he's a mad at this one yeah
yeah yeah sounded like one all right I'm
going friends all right goodbye
I'll be back in five minutes don't die
oh there we go my dudes everyone's doing
fine except for Org minion travesty
whenever you leave it's like the middle
just becomes so clustered very fast we
still have ten tool refills in the room
with us but the tools aren't an issue
it's a health I do fine on health let's
do the same thing but then when I leave
just go up top and back off that sounds
good and guys on the low ground watch
out what he does that cuz they'll agro
you but yeah we'll just all go on the
bridge when you go we'll go up what's up
[ __ ] try me Oh lots of big boys
oh yeah here we go I'm going I'm going
all right I'm going up dad run it oh I'm
crouched good don't give me reloading
reloading
I'm up on high ground okay
die you big [ __ ] oh hey oh it's very
dark there's a very dark light top your
boys still fighting thing oh yeah we're
good that one well there's a another big
guy kind of squaring his teeth shoot him
in his mouth place shoot Amore's mouth
should be
- anus like it alright I'm good on stuff
for now my sentries at 67 - so if you
guys need me to drop it I've been saving
it this whole time yeah we're good I we
actually have a bunch of tool refills in
here - yeah we we chillin on the century
situation everybody's got ammunition I'm
gonna put a sentry like I call a book
call us like emergency fallback if you
don't actually know that's gonna shoot
so there's four of them
oh I didn't reload oh man the stinky
move that was a stinky move oh very
stinky at the moment
[Music]
they're dying funny they will forget it
was some weird lag yeah they kind of
knives out a little bit and I always
thought they died funny reloading don't
you do it big boys yeah alright mark
yeah I'm fine
thought he didn't die fell on top of me
well alright I'm going have fun friends
thanks Bob is it just me or is this
round a little light yeah the world
where they all oh you had to say don't
forget to go on the bridge if you need
each other yeah I'm up here I'm a head
no reloading I thought I thought you
were guys we're like way back there and
I was making like a road you boys
alright yeah we're fine good yeah
doing okay yeah we're it's dark baby
real dark in here wow that was it was a
simple one yeah the thing is I have no
idea what this last round is if it's
special do we have to run no no just be
ready for any guys I'll be ready for
like Bette Midler to come down the
alleyway Bette Midler is but a hilarious
singer performer actress famous if I
haven't heard of her then hocus-pocus
which was all the old lady yeah that's
her okay
that was literally the only thing I know
her from taste like really famous like
so famous I don't know we're gonna need
another coat at the end of this but I
would guess yes and then maybe wrong way
to go I'll watch it and do treat it like
there is a code
I can't even get through our door please
streaming cuz I'm so absorbed into the
KQ I'm over here like the shirt off
picking my nose like oh yeah i'm
streaming just like unconsciously you
start stripping I don't know what you're
streaming oh and now my friends I'm
going now
Matt pistols are the jab I know right
those are do have we got big of course
we're not gonna leaving to work a hit
from I am out of shotty ammo oh [ __ ] I'm
in trouble I'm running back oh it's the
securityq and where's that where's that
at oh yeah entrance entrance on 62 is
that back at the beginning yeah that
sure is okay right I'm coming boys so we
kind of got a run yeah yeah we're gonna
fall back a little bit just so we can
mop him up and then push tight them
around the site and then just go it
looks like we'll just be able to [ __ ]
them up down the center right I'm like
almost completely out of ammo
yeah I'm out oh I have I have ammo packs
for you all right another big guy come
here big guy
yeah yes please thank you so much if you
have an extra Sean I would love to
submit head a little bit yes I do right
right die thank Astrid okay
let's roll let's run my dudes KSC foam
grenade - I totally forgot about oh I
didn't even know see some spawned in
this map oh we got somebody ah God I'm
laughing cuz Merrick said Cecil really
thinking about my feelings when you're
laughing are you a mo packs are in here
like some oh come on pick it up you
bastard
that's it is this the end Izumo looks
like 40% none for your wood all right
you twice
that good job boy I like barely took any
damage that whole time man and wait only
went down once twice
GG no find him a boring level okay I
hope everyone bought a good job just
made it look easy
[Music]